new research reportedly shows most of
the first coronavirus cases in the new
york area came from Europe Italy's death
rate from the virus may be leveling off
almost 18,000 people have died there
more than any other country one of the
worst affected cities is Bergamo where
Chris lives say shows the crushing
burden of the pandemic
crematoriums are buckling here so the
dead must wait in a makeshift morgue
unrefrigerated the military must hurry
to relocate them because of the heat a
church closed to parishioners shares the
burden so many bodies that you just
can't keep up we already moved 600
coffins this month this is what
flattening the curve looks like nearly
30 bodies crowded into this church but
at least it's not as bad as it used to
be well what did it look like before
completely fluid perhaps nowhere have
things been more dire than the town of
nem bro which tallies more dead per
capita than anywhere else in the country
can you count how many people you know
who have died from this disease 100
people 100 people yes yes many were
members of pure Luigi's Quincy's
mountaineering club after weeks of
catastrophic statistics Italy's
infection and death rates are finally
slowing doctors credit the stay at home
policies adopted earlier in March but
they're not out of the woods and doctors
like Giovanni Vitale are still making
life or death decisions every day you
need to decide it's very unlikely to
benefit and therefore either he makes it
or he doesn't and I remember and Tony
it's that gaze in the eyes of the dying
that doctor hopes to never see again not
to mention the disease itself as
conditions slowly improve now in Italy
but Tony he emphasized again and again
we cannot let down our guard yeah it's a
gaze no one would want to see again
Chris lives say in Rome Forest Chris
thank you very much